you can't clumping me like that yeah fam
and not let go until I prime my fingers
your dirty God and you're saying Jesus
told you to do it
[Music]
right guys girls as you already know you
get straight into the funny funnies
and the question of this week was what's
the funniest slash craziest thing you've
read or said in the group chat
as per usual read or said in the group
chat good Lord as per usual dripping off
the chin juicy juicy so actually so
these are actually just like breaking
codes even sharing this yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay it's still Anonymous it's
still Anonymous to an extent it's not an
honest to me yeah to us all right so
let's
um
one of my friends said I can feel my leg
hairs blowing in the wind
ah
sorry
oh
my Lord Lauren blowing in the wind bro
musket.com sng is the code 20 off of
sushi
good pattern that as a you I had the
worst like her your hairy brother first
of all let's calm down let's actually
calm down because in retrospect I'm
actually not that bad but in the times
where we met and then the times before
that I was bad they used to call me Teen
Wolf
your back didn't make sense to me oh I
found the lowest that lower region of
just above the battery yeah it was it
was a mess
it was a complete mess but hey yo we
move we move indeed
quotations yes I banged your man but are
you gonna leave him no so let's move on
oh my god so let's in the group chat
The Spectators would have been violent
we would have been private messages
I couldn't see that wow so let's move on
yes I banged your man but are you gonna
leave him no so let's move on
I
oh I burst into flames there's nothing
I've burst into the prominence band
there's nothing else there's nothing
else there's nothing else
yeah that's me boy that's the problem is
burn the holder that's hilarious the
whole dance
in quotes I'm not arguing with a guy who
I'm taller than
I'm not this is the group chat I'm not
arguing with a guy I'm taller than that
this is this is actually a mad question
you've asked these a lot this is a mad
question because this is something I
would think the audacity to even say it
to him because it sounds like something
she would say to him but she's just
bitching about him I'm not arguing with
someone that I have to look down upon
literally
he's a joke stop stop I'm not talking to
you stop wow wow
how can you hate my guts when you
couldn't even reach them
brother
how can you hate my guts when you
couldn't even reach them in the group
chat that one actually has to stay in a
group chat because you can't say that to
my face
because I'll read you all my hands and
pull them out yeah
fatality Style
my hands are pulling mouth that's jokes
bro said he sucked the juices off his
girl's dildo and said when he was done
[Laughter]
it's actually dread because man should
never try and be sexy I mean yeah bro
yes yes they should never try and be
sexy it's so not because I say it's I'm
so sorry to cut you off I could be like
in the ACT getting busy on top yeah you
know me I love icons yeah yeah and I'm
just there licking my lips dude also
sort of thinking she could be
reciprocating just so it's not awkward a
hundred percent she's she's she's she's
not understanding what you're doing well
I'm what I'm even about she's in here
she's like yeah you know he's like why
am I here please not please yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah just nothing
finishes literally literally just eye
contact lip licking lip biting growling
you're doing stop Fast Stop fam and none
of them will just get carried away
because man will just like lips the nut
out of her
yeah
and just be like like that and then just
try and move into the lips again
and a girl will firm and women are
worried because they'll firm anything
during this yeah telephone anything a
man won't
you could yeah yeah you could literally
never slop my nut and then lean in for
her lips because I will Dash your face
away from me it will bounce again yeah I
don't care about what like the emotions
are and all this like there's tension
and all this stop what you're doing yeah
a woman will just firm it and then
bleed ourselves dry in the in the group
chat oh that's jokes I said um you yuck
man just
and all her girls know about this now
or did he say that in the group chat
but he said bro said he sucks sorry oh
this is him in his group chat with his
boys and said man Dan guess what you
wouldn't believe you wouldn't believe
what I did for this girl I was slopping
off the dilds that she used on herself
yeah and I said
you could never say that to me oh what
the thing is I know I could never say
that it's not something I would want to
even type yeah in the first place yeah I
couldn't put confidence brother he came
with confidence that's a group chat I
never want to be in yeah that's a group
chat I never want to be in because if
man is writing that in a group chat
these men are different levels of
comfort yeah yeah different levels you
he's missed the mark because they were
they were encouraging bro you need to be
doing the most for this girl is that he
said bro I took your advice suck that
dudes that's
what did you say
what did you yes
moving on my friend accidentally sent a
video of of him banging another friend's
sister crimes commit were committed
later that day
would you mean accidentally
hey that's not an accident I I don't
think that was an accident I sent a
video of him banging another friend's
sister
my boy asked for a pic of one of us in
handcuffs so he could show his main
thing whilst he was out with these
sighting
babes look I'm not lying my boy's locked
up I'm not lying wow
crazy that's a head
that's a head that is a head that is a
head that is actually that's a lot
handcuffs who just has handcuffs bro
yeah I remember years ago this is
actually dread I was lying about my
location one time yeah I was lying about
my location yeah yeah yeah yeah one
thing that I was seeing at Uni yeah
um I was
seeing another thing yeah at the weekend
yeah and she was like where are you yeah
you know you can't sing was saying where
are you no you need to say well oh yeah
and that was with the weekend thing I'll
say less
and I was like I'm a yard so ask me a
question I'm spend quality time with my
mum leave me alone bro yeah yeah and she
was like swear you're you're chatting
[ __ ] bro where are you I said swear and
I knew my brother was actually at home I
said take a picture of mum right now
yeah random of mum right now I said take
it take a candid pic yeah yeah yeah just
her like walking up the stairs
snapped it send it to me Clutch I was
like now what say something she was like
you could have taken that picture
anytime I was like I could have taken a
picture of my mom on the stairs anytime
do you want me to find today's newspaper
shut up
these times I was feeding strawberries
so that's sick
so why are you on your face
they typed it so fast don't worry about
it
I'm doing up aphrodisiacs
[Laughter]
I used to be a liar
I used to be a liar when I was a kid wow
hilarious and I know as well
hilarious and I know as well that's
jokes
ah your standards are like again what's
the funniest craziest thing you've read
or said in a group chat your standards
are so damn low and yet they're still
taller than him stand up
stand up
arise From the Ashes fans you're burying
yourself stand up
this one heinous
my mate said his dad had cancer and
someone replied the game is the game
oh
no
the game is the game
bro the thing is it's actually dread
because facts it actually actually
because nobody gave him
the game is the game is the game bro
Father Time takes us all mother nature
takes no prisoners is the game that's
that is literally heinous Runner wow
the thing is I would have to laugh at
that yeah
too quick that could yeah that couldn't
go between two of our boys and I'm a
spectator I'll be pissing myself
I will be pissing myself
the game is the game he's gonna die
this is where I came to confide yeah and
then look for shoulders I must say the
game is the game what's the move man
said tis what's this
yeah
twt it is what it is
she was shaped like a bag of baked beans
a bag not a tin brother a bag of baked
beans let that sink in
like this you don't gotta shape that
that's when you yeah yeah you have to
hold it by the seal yeah and if you let
it drop into your hand it falls over
your head yeah yeah it's a sloppy mess
she was shaped like a bag of baked beans
that's an alliteration brother wow yeah
man nuts that's a not tin brother a bag
that's loosey-goosey that's loose wow
that's Wayward weight
[Music]
[Laughter]
God each time he comes over he shits
with the door open okay stop
literally stop with the door open
my sister randomly said I finally sucked
dick last night
nah
nah
what do you mean finally how long have
you been trying for fam why is this a
goal why why is this a goal of yours I
finally sucked dick last night in a
group chat nah stop stop stop stop stop
finally will send me
finally
thank you
does anyone else's coochie lips cramp up
even imagine what she's talking about
can't fathom what she's on Gucci lips
cramp up
that doesn't make sense
took a pregnancy test good news is I'm
not pregnant bad news is I'm fat for no
reason
that was me and my T levels
that was
just I'm a [ __ ] I'm a soft little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
soft little bit
hilarious
his small D will tickle me for the rest
of my life
for God's sake
for the rest of my life not it's so fast
there's no chance of me getting an STD
brah
that's wild do you think that's actually
a thing that can't be a thing
not it's so quick there's no way I'm not
even gonna bother getting tested
that is so cool it was in and out
literally
I accidentally sent a new to the family
group chat it was completely ignored
I don't know where to start with wow
it's been in my head I couldn't see
you and then someone else just starts
chatting about the rest the rest of the
day it was completely ignored that's
terrifying I couldn't go home I'm not
going home and if I am home I'm leaping
out the window
I promise it's not even a joke I'm not
looking my mum in the face ever again
come on you can't I'm running away from
home I'm actually running away from home
bro completely ignored not impossible
you know because I know you might have
whispering right down there I know you
better Whispering down there silent
screams
my dad can never look up at my mum and
just look back down again
this is our son you know
facts oh that's painful I've just
stepped in human poo at self-service in
Tesco
mad there's certain moments in your life
where you just like
like a city on the stairs over there the
other day like I hope I just like slip
and crack my head
yeah I hope I slip and then the fall
just takes yeah
because I can't live like this
I actually can't live like this yeah
that's jokes
a girl sent a pic of a man in the chat
my boy said he'd look like me and I say
ill she doesn't talk to me anymore
I can't stand when people say I look
like anyone oh brother I can oh yeah for
you for me it's a daily struggle bro
it's a day I get DMC and I thought this
was James like why are you even
messaging me this like why are you even
messaging me this bro I get that about
you sometimes as well what are we doing
yeah this was James I look at
swiper just me I kissed my team and
swipe off the one in Stratford the other
day was it when you said I thought he
[Music]
[Laughter]
just to do it up a little Munch coming
back to the stew and I heard some boys
whispered I'm thinking what did he say I
was calculating to myself James
obviously didn't hear I was like you
would never believe what these men said
he said what he said Oh I thought that
was Craig David
if I knew who it was you would have had
to hold me back
if I knew who said it you would have had
to hold me back I could have heard that
Craig David
grips the escalator because I was gonna
flip it live it have you seen his head
shape
Craig David of all people couldn't
believe that livid I couldn't believe
that brother livid
that's what I get reminded of on a daily
basis light skin is just light it could
be anyone yeah you could be anyone this
is what these men are saying yeah
literally wow I've never heard anyone
say Craig David before yeah never mind
bro
the worst thing that's the worst thing
I've had spun me freak David I've got a
few more all right cool I don't like old
men I collect Antiques and pensions
right
her titties probably get caught under
her armpit
on that laying down
it just falls out yeah that Alabama
spread
nah
the Bama spread I hit last but not least
I know she's ugly but I have no other
options so I've been there that yeah
yeah I've been there
options oh yeah bro end of the night
Kebab chicks
scooping whatever yeah yeah because you
have to be in the early ish because the
penguin Penguins will get scooped up
yeah straight away gone before you order
your chicken you're the one you're
dealing with the things with garlic Mayo
around the mouth oh God got it right
around my head on the table once
you're off head on the table makeup
scattered a neighbor's scattered she
looks up at you mascara dripping down
her face she tries to give you a little
wink little wink with the eyelashes
work eyelashes wonk yeah and you're just
like Jesus what what am I doing but I'm
horny
I need something
yeah it's disgusting I'm so happy I've
never actually followed through with
that but that price still might as we've
all been there now you're sober up
quickly oh
oh so yes you do yes you do God that's
disgusting God that's disgusting have
the fattest wanker you're getting yeah
yeah you wake up thankful
[Music]
every time you speak Arabic
sweets mom you wake up
[Laughter]
again again tonight inshallah
um right anyway guys welcome back
welcome back welcome back this is
episode 245. wow you're chilling with
your boys J Money And Fire loaf ways and
we are grateful for your attention we
definitely do not deserve it but if you
wanted to give us a little bit more and
if you want to indoctrinate yourself
into the cult baby culture over here
with SMG you need to head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
it's gonna cost you a measly three pound
a month MP a day you need to run the P
to SMG okay guys and join our cult join
our family
um enjoy three plus years of content
that we've had over there the unsets of
content unedited content all the old
stuff that will get us canceled today is
over there on patreon and you also get
full access to our Discord Channel where
you get to introduce yourself to all the
other cult babies discussion points and
everything that's coming uh with the
show and all that
All That Jazz stuff all that good stuff
guys um if you are watching us on
YouTube please please please please
please please please
um give us a generous subscription
subscription we're on the truck two
months on the truck we've hit 100K a
month uh of new subscribers and we could
not be more grateful guys thank you so
so so so so much it means the world to
us okay you have no idea finally guys if
you are listening to this um any podcast
uh app
please give us a follow and please give
us a nice review five stars is always
preferable but whatever you say say with
your chest and we'll firm it whatever
your view is we'll firm it okay because
that's what we do it's a non-censored
platform all right
so guys
I've got a little rant to start off
today hit us I need to get this out
there so this episode comes out on
Monday okay so I might have just enough
time I need to get this out there before
the media takes takes it runs with it so
on my way here yeah
I ran away from charity workers
Fam I'm not gonna lie to you I'm just
gonna put it out there and push them and
ran I was missing for the media gets a
hold of this before shaver gets a hold
of it yeah and it spins it wherever they
want I need to put the narrative out
there okay so
I was walking through Stratford East
London earlier today minding my business
on the way here to the studio okay
walking walking walking walking and
these these men are scattered about
asking for donations for this I don't
even know what they wanted money for all
I know is they want a donation for
sighting
I get approached I've got airpods in I
get approached and I said I couldn't
hear him so I said sorry brother I said
nothing
yeah I'm in a rush I haven't got my
wallet like stop not today not today not
today fam he stopped me on my chest and
he said sir sir he said sir he thinks
he's clever he said sir he was a black
bear probably like 17 18. thickest
glasses I've seen yeah woolly hats yeah
so sir sir I know who you are I said
brother
I'm not really I'm in a bit of a rushes
I don't know who you are your name's
James and you do she gives with he said
and I said thank you sir nice to meet
you bro I was like my lip with equipment
I said all right bro man thank you so
much he followed me said sir sir and I
was like thanks I said I tried to talk
over him I said have a great day
aggressively but not aggressively
aggressively but not aggressively
gently removed his hand off my chest so
have a great day I went to turn
and he said he said no no so so please
please please I stopped I said I paused
my tank I said brother what do you want
what do you actually want he said you
know what I'd want more than anything I
said what he said a donation
yeah manipulative little [ __ ] he said I
would like more than anything today to
just have a donation I said swear before
I had a chance his Bridge would come up
said I know you oh I said hey hey
there was a gap in the middle so I was
like I'm just gonna skirt through the
middle before I had a chance thanks
third one oh you're my man they're all
looking for donations now oh all three
of them they're working together yeah
yeah all looking for donations Fam I'm
not gonna lie I said guys guys it's been
lovely to me I've got to go and it's a
donation donation fam I grabbed the
jacket the puffer jacket I grabbed it of
the fur one on the left yeah and just
gave him a ha ha and I stormed off
stormed off but you know when like your
your head straight but your eyes are
looking beautiful yeah I don't know if
they're following man
made it into the station straight up the
stairs I was breathing on that and I was
thinking that's well that's my career
done isn't it that's my career done
because they're going to go to the Sun
the daily yeah and they're gonna say top
boy James
hates kids oh sorry he hates kids and he
hates donations yeah he loves blood
diamonds
whatever cause they were after yeah
James supports cancer like Saturn oh my
Dave so I thought I put the narrative
out there it's not my fault yeah yeah
yeah yeah they use my notoriety against
me for a donation and I just don't play
that [ __ ] blocked you yeah yeah they
cornered man and obviously when your boy
gets in the corner he starts getting
defensive you do so I had to fight my
way out and there were no donations made
today
so sorry anyway there's always speaking
of Stratford remember when we're sitting
down having food this was on Tuesday
and then that random brother came up to
me and said sorry sorry excuse me are
you Ghanaian or Nigerian I said what fam
you kept your calls you kept yours the
thing is I was gripping the seat
I don't know why or how I did it just I
just happened to keep my call yeah he
looked at me dead in my book looking
down I was sitting down he was looking
down at me like this he said he was
shivering shivering I just wanted I had
a mask on he did he took it down like
this excuse me I want to ask you a
question are you Garnier or Nigerian I
said excuse me he said are you going in
a Nigerian I said what has that answer
got to do whatever question you want to
ask me yeah yeah yeah and he said I
don't want to take up much of your time
and I said I whatever you're about to
say I haven't got money he put his face
mask back on kissy Steve I still knocked
off stormed off I couldn't believe it
yeah yeah bro stormed off he didn't care
I didn't care he just wanted to ask for
money in Europe because he thought
that's how you get yeah get away once
I'm thinking that's the worst possible
way to go all right he's tired of it and
the thing is I knew he was Nigerian by
his accent so I wasn't even entertaining
it bro I wasn't entertaining the brother
then the next prayer the umaguage fight
came Farm you were just saying change
changes he said money oh yeah he said he
was shaking money money money money
yeah we need to change the dynamic yes
certain needs to happen I get people are
poor I get it's called but the sign
needs to happen yeah get your hand out
my face and it's a double negative
because obviously no one carries change
or cash anymore it's rare So this man
tried to to meet the demand and it's a
couple of men have been investing in
these these little card machines
but if I see a card machine in your in
your hand
I don't know the backstory all I know is
you've got money enough to be a card
machine but you don't need any money
from me in fact where's that going to
where's why do you have a car you've got
a bank account you've got satin you've
got identity whose internet are you
connected to in fact all I'm seeing in
my head is right cool you've got a card
machine which means you've got a bank
account if you've got a bank account
means you've got ID if you've got ID you
can sort some kind of housing situation
so you've got an ni number yeah you've
got an A number and it's your pass yeah
your legal and your past yeah little did
I know you took three days off food to
afford this thing
do you know what I mean I use next Mouse
password
money money money yeah please please I
haven't eaten in days and I'm like oh is
that card machine
who do you think you're trying to fool
old man get out my face money money oh
so you could take my money into your BMW
I think so I don't think so not today
sir yeah it's horrible out there oh my
days it's actually horrible
um but yeah anyway so one thing that I
I've been holding off chatting all week
about and we've not even been speaking
about it I haven't we haven't the role
anime right now and so funny I actually
saw a tick tock about this this morning
I swear uh one guy had the top 10 ranked
anime based on like views and popularity
okay currently running okay and um top
three right now is literally chainsaw
chainsaw man my hero my hero blue lock
standard
anime right now and there's a couple
more in that top ten where I've not even
heard of and he said they're fire if you
see it again I need to see it again and
uh hopefully I liked it I'm hoping I
liked it I might not have but I hope I
liked it if not I'm sure I can Google it
okay bro he said there was whatever was
at number seven he was like that doesn't
make sense how that's number seven that
doesn't make sense out of number seven
hey he said it should be competing with
his top three dogs okay bro he said this
season of anime yeah is crazy and it's
this hands down I'm willing to knock on
wood on this
so far from what I'm watching this is
the best caliber of anime I've seen in
my life I've been watching Adam since I
was 16. yeah yeah because I can agree
with that as well because there are
times when you're watching Naruto and
you're just only watching Naruto and you
think [ __ ] this is [ __ ] hard yeah but
there's never been like a back to back
to back to back to back where three or
four or five different animes are
popping week after week after week ah
pin bro chainsaw up chain a chainsaw
massacre chainsaw man's a different
League of anime Miss makima is the most
OP person I've ever seen and this thing
that she was doing this twisting say say
the name XYZ and then she just
he is a different breaker bro he is a
difference it's a different bread it
actually looks like a fox it's crazy
yeah yes how they thought of that is
hard yeah bro the chick in the remember
the that floor that hotel uh when they
got stuck on floor yeah man yeah yeah
she went on to the next episode oh
didn't she just she was she grabbed the
knife and she did the first the the iPad
she had said she's got the moves but she
ain't got the she's too scared yeah yeah
she's got the moves and she's like I'm
thinking she's going to want to quit but
I need to keep her now speaking what are
you keeping her for bro she's a [ __ ]
bro she stepped her [ __ ] up stepped up
that day wow amazing chainsaw Minds
unbelievable and just as I thought it
couldn't get any better the last few
episodes wow
plots twists everywhere have you seen
the most recent one yes brother is the
most recent one no it's not
no it's not a new one came out yesterday
oh I've not seen it it's nothing really
happens okay the ending is it's a oh
to be fair I was wondering if I even
spot on that it's okay it's nothing so
basically
what has happened is um you know those
those two workers that have the scar
both have the same scarcity yes yes
obviously Miss mackem is um they work
for her now because she's the boss yes
oh yeah because she's they're from like
division one between one and four yeah
she's sent them to go see homeboy yes
his name accio I can't remember yeah
yeah they've sent it to Jose homeboy and
they said to him do you know what they
said to him they said bro I know you
like having up contracts with these
these uh Devils we're gonna need you to
get a contract with a serious devil now
he's basically said the consciously go
I'll push your contract the devil's that
he's moving with Fox devil curse devil
pussyos we're gonna need you to come
with us and get a contract with a real
devil if you're ever gonna have any
anything to do with the gun devil you
need to you need to pattern us where you
need to patent up okay same time
same time
um what's her name power yeah I haven't
seen her in a minute from power and uh
denji yeah are training okay training
okay you know who they're training with
who
the breath
who's always at the graveyard
with the scar across his face and said I
need a hunter who's tapped yes yes he
said I need a hunter who's tapped isn't
that the guy that was at a grave of
isn't that the chick with the eye patch
her like her yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
he's warm hey he's wow
that's me tonight bro chainsaw Minds off
the hook it is off the hook it's the
best anime I've seen in a long time
episodes in yeah yeah
blue lock for a sport anime is crazy
it's still not it's still nowhere no I
wouldn't say nowhere near as good as
Haiku Haiku took my song yeah
I couldn't believe how volleyball yeah
yeah taking the piss a volleyball say
less but blue lock different gravy very
strong anime isagi's spatial awareness
yeah it doesn't make sense it's crazy
the way he's sniffing out goals bro when
uh long hair done yes yes stepped up and
just had a kale hamster money yeah he's
gone read him crazy
[Music]
crazy
Mad solid and my hero Academia diabetes
dogs
total Rocky was on the road
snap the [ __ ] out of it snap out of it
whatever you're doing right now do it
later we need to scrap yeah he's coming
bro well plot twist family and devil was
talking about how
um
about how he didn't have the half cold
half hot but I didn't care because he
had more Talent than me yeah yeah I was
thinking wrong I was like swear down he
said he's my moral Talent than me bro I
didn't care I was ready to train him to
be number one hero he lost his life out
there
man canceled him and sent for him on the
same day bro Abby dabby's on stuff on
stuff and that's just the most recent
episode the past few episodes
mad deku's been on the ropes on the
ropes on the road homeboy just won't die
he won't he just won't where's his name
something like that yeah when they
spoiler when they slice mom I want to
say his name slice my man's leg off it
didn't make sense
crazy plot twists
Man City what what Wednesday he sliced
it himself
he said it brilliant by eye contact yeah
just slice his leg off and get kept
staring
wrong my Hero's on a different thing
yeah yeah
so yeah find me that bread that has that
list and he's washable I'll find it yeah
because anime right now is is on a
different breed of like quality and this
is in between Demon Slayer and JuJu yeah
they're chilling right now they're
chilling demons comes back in March
April I think I've seen it yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be strong yeah
Summers spring summer is going to be
naughty yeah and there's definitely
there's definitely gonna be a chance on
my movie there has to be change
someone's unbelievably good unbelievably
good doesn't even make sense in January
as well next month Jesus apparently you
feel it's like this completely different
twist to um season one oh really yeah
but apparently still very good it's all
right say less it's more like less arms
more like storyline
I'm here for it but yeah you guys you
definitely definitely definitely
definitely chainsaw man my hero Academia
blue lock if you've never seen them
jump on yeah I get DMS literally every
other day saying what anime should I
watch what animation watch sharp my hero
Academia you can binge that for months
now if you want to relax because there's
six seasons literally then we've got uh
blue lock banging and Chainsaw man is I
it's only 10 episodes in so it's so
Haram to say yeah it's so yeah it's so
horrible to say this is the best thing
I've ever seen But the enjoyment I'm
having when watching it wow
unparalleled oh my
bleach blades Oh my days
bro are you up today yes
Sam came back she's not playing cars
yeah he's not he's not he's so strong
yeah he's so strong yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah wow how could we forget about
bleach wow bleach is going off
wow he's so strong this is the best
bleach ever brother crazy crazy
did you ever um start mob psycho season
three nah so season three is one of them
ones where it's same with season one of
season two where like slow burner a bit
of arms then there's like a middle
filler crap yeah yeah after that I don't
these last two episodes hard
he has been going off swear I've not
seen him like this James he's
he's going off say this okay I'll
happily jump on because I love season
one season two but yeah
um yeah do you know what I also saw
another Tick Tock the other day they're
saying the manga of this is wham so I
don't know where the anime or is fire
force
oh yeah I've seen one or two I've seen
yeah so have I oh but I just stopped
okay it's not okay I've seen freeze now
yeah that's why I was on updated
yesterday on fireforce and it was saying
it was out season three I don't know if
it says season three but you know when
we knew on Crunchyroll yeah yeah you've
got the new tab yeah and it says like
how many hours ago the new episode came
out okay he said five was there say less
say for that safer I could be wrong
safer though because fire I binge that
yeah yeah I binge that but I think I
still might be behind a while because
the last episode I saw spoiler alert was
after so you know when he did this light
speed thing with his brother yes yes yes
he had with his brother yes a few
episodes after that he had a Wham fight
with the number one Captain squad one
Captain yes yes I remember the iPad yes
I remember that I think that's the last
episode okay okay okay something around
there was the last episode so I feel
like that might be back a bit I can't
really record to be honest but I do
remember that all right
first episode which comes out comes up
flying yeah there's some captain sins in
that [ __ ] yeah for all what is it the
squad
depending I can do that
Eclipse thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly that yeah yeah exactly that he's
off yeah he is he's got like the rengeku
on something else and he's got two
different itings yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you yeah you can say that perfect
that's exactly what he does it's the
best out of her yeah yeah yeah he murked
that demon thing with that he murked it
yeah fireforce added to list my people
fireforce is hard watch that um watch
that but yeah man well right let's take
a very quick break from the shenanigans
guys we need to pay some bills and the
best way to do that is spread awareness
about our friends over at manscaped okay
come on SO 2023 is on its way and the
last thing you want is to be the guy
with pubes getting in your way of making
it your best yet okay there's a lot of
barriers out there a lot of haters out
there the last thing we want to to get
in the way is our own body hair okay
first so the manscape lawnmower 4.0 is
the leader of the performance package
4.0 or as I like to call it the perfect
package for my package okay my Escape
engineered the ultimate groin and body
trimmer by focusing on intelligent
functionality and an incredibly
comfortable grooming experience and guys
if you want to jump on the bandwagon
along with seven million men worldwide
all you need to do is punch in the code
s n g Sierra November golf you already
know at manscape.com and that's going to
give you a humble like like 20 off plus
free shipping guys one more time the
code is sng zero November golf the
location is manscape.com and the reward
is 20 off and free shipping let's get
back to the fun did you ever watch um
into was it into the abyss or made uh
what's it called
made by abys or something like that it's
about something something the abyss
um two little about two little kids ring
the bell but you have to watch it okay
okay made in Abyss I think it's called
made in a Biz okay you have to watch it
it's amazing is it arms is it
psychological is it it's a bit of
everything okay it's like it reminds me
of it's like Adventure but Dark
Adventure okay so it reminds me it gives
me like promised Neverland vibes okay
you never watched problems oh God you
have to watch that one as well
Christ
um yeah made in abys yeah yeah
phenomenal okay
phenomenal anime send me a list I need
that Tick Tock list as well all right
say let's lsls anyway I've got a little
bit of thread hit me so we can have a
couple more laughy laughs at me I love
it when you have for us
it's a very very very small one so it's
literally just a couple minutes but um
why are you laughing literally just a
couple minutes
um right so a little one yeah
so the the initial tweet was
y'all be exposing the wildest [ __ ] when
you broke up what do you mean you didn't
go on a date in three years
then people just carried on
what do you mean he gave you abortion
money twice and you kept the kid
I think I saw that I saw that one I saw
that one yeah yeah abortion money twice
wow and you kept the kid wow bro when I
read that I was like what are we on
about yeah yeah
like what do you mean he doesn't own a
toothbrush wow fam what do you mean he
doesn't own a toothbrush wow where's he
living fam and this is all stuff that
they beat out after the breakup
mad to me women will sit through
anything if they feel secure and loved
facts they'll sit through anything and
they'll justify whatever actually if the
D is good oh if he's good they're
cooking up a Munch yeah if the D's good
and he's always home on time yeah yeah
yeah like I don't care about your
surround yeah he doesn't have a
toothbrush and what and what that's my
man you're talking about life
is the love of my life and he protects
me yes I'm a protector he doesn't have
time to brush his teeth because he's
provided he's busy making money yeah
sorry little man are stuck at home
that's why they're brushing teeth
what do you mean he hasn't had a job in
seven months
seven months seven
that's so specific I'd be so homeless
seven months he hasn't had a job that is
very specific he's not even looking he's
definitely he's chilling he was gas to
get sacked
like what do you mean he's only got two
shirts and three pairs of jeans
more jeans and you have shirts what kind
of rotation is that that's
what kind of rotation is that yeah yeah
last one
I was with my baby dad for seven years
the first two years is the only time he
took me out and it was only three times
I had to let a [ __ ] know what he's on
you didn't that's the thing as well like
you did it keep it to yourself
keep it to yourself oh man that's big I
had to let the next [ __ ] know what he's
on he's not gonna take you out I hope
you're ready for that is what she's
saying I hope the thing is as well they
forget that the other women are just as
close-minded as you yeah in a honeymoon
phase in a honeymoon phase and X can
never message a brand new thing like
just so you know he never took me out
could you reply and say that's all of
your business in fact because we've been
out she could be lying yeah we've been
bit now she could be like yeah she's
probably lying but we stay out yay we're
active active so that's embarrassing for
you and I don't know why you'd bait
yourself out like that a shameful you
yuck and you wonder why you're not
together that's this is why you're the
ex why do you even know I'm his new team
facts stop stalking yeah yeah get over
yourself he told me he he literally told
me you were crazy and this is and this
is what you're doing this is proof yeah
it literally yeah
but yeah something yeah women stop
baiting out the things that were wrong
with him because it's just embarrassing
is is it so it says a lot about you
doesn't own a toothbrush why are you
with him yeah
those are the questions
can you imagine going into a girl's
bathroom and there's just no toothbrush
in there there's everything but a
toothbrush every night she's just coming
to bed
every night she's in bed before you
how active question how long until you
bring it up this is a thing that you
just started dating yeah yeah yeah
banging yeah banging every time breath
doesn't stink nothing
but you stayed you stay around the house
one time yeah you don't think about it
yeah you give it another week you go
around there again
you notice you notice it because you've
asked can I brush my teeth yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and she's like
gang yeah yeah yeah so you already
brought your toothbrushes obviously I
knew I stand I brought my teeth you
brush your teeth and she's in bed she's
just in bed waiting for you okay another
follow-up question before I answer did I
bring my own toothpaste you put uh
investigation yes
it's like you bought your own toothpaste
you go in the bathroom there's no
toothbrush in there there's no
toothpaste in there but you didn't
notice until you went in the bedroom
yeah put your toothbrush and toothpaste
away in your little travel bag
um and she's just laying in bed and
you're thinking Hmm so you don't say
anything again obviously because you
want to smash yeah facts third time you
stay around there this is like two days
later now
you go brush your teeth again you're
looking now for a toothbrush or
toothpaste no mouthwash no floss yeah
yeah no nothing scattering you're
opening it's not here yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the thing with me I would
probably
and you said a breath does a stick no no
it's mad because knowing me obviously
I'll do what I did on night too I'll
still sleep and smash but I wake up the
next day let's say we both have to dip
I'll make sure during the next day it's
one of them ones where we both have to
leave the yard around similar times yes
yeah yeah
and it's I'm gonna be on a on a cutesy
thing like I'm gonna brush my teeth
while she's in the shower or something
or vice versa I need to see you brush
your teeth in the morning I have to see
it
because I've been over twice now yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's no toothpaste
there's no toothbrush there's nothing
here the mouthwash there's nothing yeah
she has no intention of having it there
she doesn't even have the little holder
like the toothbrush hold on nothing see
that that she didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah she just got the same thing and she
moved in because she's she's stays not
brushing her teeth yo yo yeah I'd have
I'd I would wait till the next morning
and be like
did you brush your teeth have you
brushed like because I would have
brushed mine I would have brought you
brush your side in the time that you've
been there you press your teeth twice
now yeah we're going through two two
cycles facts and she's not touched nuts
and you can't find nothing
what's your first yeah what is your
first question are you gonna say so
you're saying your First interaction is
are you gonna brush your teeth where's
your toothbrush babes where's your teeth
that's exactly
I might be Sly and be like I've got
because I've got the electronics
I'll be like I've got an electronic one
or a regular tube yeah I I would be on a
jokey joke what do you want a manual
thing or an electric tank
what kind of two toothbrush you use I'd
have to
I'd have to play dumb with her response
yeah it's like no she's not got a
toothbrush I know it and I'm actually
looking at her like hmm
where is it or whatever she replies
where is it because I've not seen you
brush your teeth very respectively yeah
respectfully I've not seen you brush
your teeth but your breath stays banging
so I'm confused I'm very confused
because your tongue must be white no it
must be white yeah and that's what
causes the steak breath yes
I'll be uh I'll be scared
okay so now sorry she's told you oh
babes like I don't I was just like the
way the way we were raised we just
didn't brush teeth just raw doggies yeah
we just actually like my mom obviously
my mum was like very natural yeah so she
thought like as long as a lot of fiber
in your diet the the like yeah the
fibrous tentacles and all them thing
there or scrub your teeth
she's like I just eat a little wheat I'm
buck like I eat a lot of that stuff it
really like gets in there yeah and gets
the bacteria out yeah yeah and I eat
like a lot of like antibacterial stuff
your mints polos I'm addicted to polos
so long story short baby you don't brush
your teeth don't brush my teeth cool and
this is this will be in the morning I'll
be like cool cool cool what's your day
saying I'll let you do your thing I'm
gonna do my thing
that's it yeah we can't because I would
as annoying as it is
banging or whatever I would be so Jarred
to bring that to the group chat because
there's
because you man wouldn't even be able to
Fathom what I'm saying yeah because you
know bro yeah because obviously her
teeth were murked and there's nothing
you can say to prove otherwise because I
don't have a picture
yeah yeah so yeah it's it's nuts yeah
because I will be in there and actually
like type in paragraphs at you and I was
like you know I was actually mad fellas
is that like he showed us this thing and
like look at her body for one second and
you already know what fuja did no one
yeah
he saw the bra size and he saw the that
Gap and he just ignored the filth and
toxins that she was breathing in his
face because that's the dog he is
isn't that right guys
everyone would agree haha yeah yeah yeah
yeah
guys typical typical not my fault I
didn't know I didn't clock until three
days later yeah fam yeah and if that's
the thing is like if you didn't clock
then that's like you probably that isn't
me problem yeah yeah and then someone
will be in there never me boy probably
rev remember being that Nev that could
never be I'd smile from a mile away
you didn't want to smell it facts yeah
you didn't want to smell it had a pinch
nose thing
that's mad disgraceful not to me yeah
that's that can't run that can't run
anyway I've got um I've got a trash news
bet
um
west southwest passenger arrested after
she tried to open the plane door
mid-flight she claimed Jesus told her to
do it
and on rawly Southwest Airlines
passenger who tried to open the aircraft
store mid-fly then bit another passenger
claimed Jesus told her to do it
according to the court doctor do that
too or just the adulting both did you
install it twice opened the door and
then bite her
was on the Ohio bound flight from Texas
on a Saturday afternoon when she
allegedly became frustrated our flight
attendants prevented her from reaching
the emergency exit
when a fellow passenger interviewed by
tackling her she responded by biting the
person on the thigh refusing to let go
until the victim forced her fingers into
her jaw wow a crazed woman then started
whacking her head on the plane floor
claiming Jesus told her to fly to Ohio
and Jesus told her to open the door
according to the criminal complaint
she's expected to face charges of
assault within a married within Maritime
and Tourette territorial jurisdiction
and interference with the flight crew
members and attendants
that's mad to me I can never be on a
flight James
and a crazy woman's just trying to draw
for the lever and a fellow passenger
says stop and she yells me to the point
where I have to just dig our fingers in
her jaw to get her off that pain would
I'd let her open the door without pain I
would be screwed yeah yeah
I wouldn't care
sorry gender roles would not play A Part
anymore oh you're swinging a joke um I
wouldn't even know what I would do yeah
yeah she would lose a couple teeth yeah
yeah because that's mad to me
you can't clamp on man's you can't clamp
on me like that yeah family and not let
go until I prime my fingers
your dirty God and you're saying Jesus
told you to do it oh she has to open the
door man my immediate thing is like how
much do I if I'm the woman yeah how bad
do I ride for Jesus because
like this whole Jesus told me to do it
my second because I said what and what
did you say
oh she looks like an Elam as well
beautiful
it has mugs off the backing on the floor
I know she bit hard as well
she ain't even got a bra on bro she's
just ah freelancer yeah
she has it as well
oh she's done now I don't know who let
her on the flashlight
bro that's mad that is West's brother
but yeah one thing for me is like if
Jesus like approached me tomorrow in my
obviously psycho says yeah and said bro
I'm gonna need you to fly down higher
and then when we're 30 000 feet I need
to yank her with a passenger I don't
think so though but like bro are you
actually Jesus are you the devil are you
the serpent because you're spitting
serpent bars to me that's scary stuff
yeah what's the justification what is
this for yeah
yeah because I'm just anyone I'm any
brand yeah no no no no I'm good I've got
a life to live as well yeah allow me
yeah yeah I don't I don't think that's
my time tomorrow yeah it sounds mad like
what's the worst because I know what's
gonna happen if I open that door right
what are you gonna do to me if I don't
right yeah these are the questions yeah
yeah
what's the ROI on this
because this is crazy it's actually
cracked yeah there's no way I don't get
too ask me to do it
honestly I don't care who else Zeus
himself has asked me to do it that will
strike you a lot yeah yeah strike me
then because I'm not falling from there
it doesn't I'd rather have a lightning
butt to the Head
so what is all this Fair that's nuts
yeah that's crazy that's crazy that's
absolutely crazy
it comes crazy
um right I've got um a dilemma to finish
on okay oh gang oh when I read this it
just got it got worse and worse and
worse those are ones I love right so
this is a young man who's been through
what I think most
non-alpha young men have been through
right okay and when I say young like
Alpha is a spectrum you can be Alpha in
one room and definitely not the next
factual
um right so young man just picture that
okay
um
Christ right so Matt said the other day
I went out clubbing with my friends we
sat down for a bit before going back to
dance while I was dancing I saw this
girl I saw that this girl was looking in
my area our eyes met a couple times
before I asked my friend if she was
looking at me or him he said he wasn't
sure either I ended up moving a bit
um I ended up moving a bit as a random
guy was in between the two of us and saw
that she's still looking our way
some random black guy comes up behind
her and they end up lips in
me and my friend realize me and my
friend realized that she must have just
been into black guys and left it at that
random thing to say she must have just
been into black guys and left it at that
however yeah while she's wrapped up in
this guy's arms she's staring at me
[Laughter]
I'll be thinking what do you want
perhaps tell me what you want me to do
tell me what you want and what you
really really want bam because I need to
know yeah yeah oh God so
staring at me also scare me bro um so
why should you write up in this guy's
arm she's staring at me I would grips
you like oh I would be staring at you
already is she looking at me I said
family has to leave it I have to leave
it bro leave it she's moving mad
right so her and this black guy I don't
know if this guy's black or white but he
keeps I'm zooming in on the on the
profile pic now what color are you
because
the black thing just keeps coming up
what color are you yeah right
all right Herman this black guy have
moved pretty much next to us
but I see the black guy type something
right
I mean we get it all right so having
this black guy have moved
so
shortly black guy right okay last one
all right cool let me go through it
so her and this black guy have moved
pretty much next to us I see the black
guy type something on his phone but I
couldn't see exactly what she speaks to
him and then types something on his
phone as well by the way this girl had a
friend with her but she left when whilst
they were texting okay
the guy left the girl and went to speak
to a bouncer meaning this girl was right
besides us now and decides to dance with
us
a part of me doesn't want to interact
with her as me seeing her lips a guy in
front of me was a turn off but the fact
that she was staring at me while getting
held by that guy was a turn on
internal confidence bro internal
conflict we end up vibing with her and I
don't try to make a move her friend
comes back and from the hand gestures as
from the hand gestures I saw I guess she
was saying uh to go somewhere else
the girl said no I'm staying here and
pointed right at the floor
so they stayed dancing with us then this
white guy comes out of nowhere
backs the girl up into a group of people
and starts lipsing up her as well
so now his team's been missed by two
guys a black guy and a white guy yeah
yeah yeah
same thing happens again which is
getting held
as she starts to stare at me again oh my
goodness the black guy comes back and is
like yo what's going on and the girl
pars him off so he was the black girl
pass the black guy off okay so he walks
away the girl goes back to Lipson the
white guy and me and my friend conclude
that she just belongs to the streets and
we go somewhere else yeah
so
question
um questions
should I have one should I have gone uh
should I have gone for this girl two how
can I be more confident to interact with
girls at a club so long story short he's
in a club he sees a girl he likes
Parisa
says banging she's watching me I'm
watching her gang there's someone in our
way I get up before that you think is
you looking at me yeah yeah you look in
a mirror looking at her I ask you bro
I'm pretty sure she's staring at me
someone dancing in our way I get up to
carry and staring at her and some black
guy just moves up grabs her chin and
lifts up
and I'm like for God's sake and I'm like
well she probably just like black guys
yeah so let's just leave it there just
loves black yes clearly
the Viper Phillips one round of black
guy that should just means she loves
black guys and I don't there's nothing
else to be said about it so it's
whatever so the black guy lipses her
winds up cradles her holds that time
holds it tight and what is this
happening now she's got a clear line of
you with me again she's praying me again
and I'm thinking Jesus I don't know if
I'm a [ __ ]
I don't know if I'm a cop or a voice
watching her with next man like this is
turning me on
why are you staring at me like this what
you want yeah what you want to do what
do you want to do about it
so anyway so that wine and wine and
whining they make their way over to near
us the black guy pisses off
coincidentally black guy pisses off and
I'm like calm she's here she's clearly
about it she sees me I see her she sees
my boy my boy sees her and she just
starts dancing we're dancing and we're
doing the little yeah yeah
get money
then don't touch me come off me come off
me
[Applause]
um so that now happens I'm thinking all
right she's down she's actually down
like she's fully fully down like I I
might have to do something about it her
friend comes up says let's go and the
girl's like I'm staying here I don't
know what you're on about I'm staying
here Carry On Dancing Carry On Dancing a
random white guy comes through the crowd
sees her says yum grabs the same thing
grabs her chin lips is her lips is a
winds up and cradles her
stares at me once again
and I'm thinking what's going on
this girl's been giving me Vibes all
night and she's Loosey Goosey any man
that actually tries it yeah there's like
a common denominator that she's gonna
lift them yeah yeah and it could have
been me from the job from early from
before midnight it could have been me
and I'll turn it to you after this
second time now and you're like wow
wow I could have been you twice yeah now
you're at a point where you actually
can't live sir you cannot yeah you
cannot lip Sir James you cannot
and I'm just here just hard as hell vex
because that could have been things that
could have been me she didn't even see
these breads before she didn't see them
she'd been seeing me all night and
because I'm such a [ __ ] all I never
accept her yeah I'm confident man I'm
just going in lips and whining that's it
lips are white dips
and she hasn't broken eye contact once
livid so he's saying what can I do next
time this happens how can I make sure
that I pattern this because I just can't
see my base as lips in guys every night
because
because I'll just end it
bro you have to obviously confidence is
different from everyone or for everyone
in any given situation
but you just have to go with your gut
and your gut was telling you to move to
her you've got millions telling you to
move to her but you were shocked because
you were thinking initially you're
thinking are you staring at me or are
you staring at my boy and you were
having this moment for for a bit too
long and she's still staring
but you took too long my brother way too
long someone else swooped it because the
black brother at the back was thinking
she's staring at me yeah right she's
staring at me and she wants something
yeah let me swoop it she wasn't even
looking his Direction but that's how
confident he was she's just like I'm
obviously probably the darkest guy in
here she's looking for me she's looking
for me yeah she saw me a minute ago now
she's looking for me I'm just gonna go
right I'm just gonna go I grabbed the
chin and I lipsta she's down she's down
so yeah it's um it's one of those ones
where you always it's crazy because you
always know what you are gonna do after
the situation has passed always
hindsights 20 20. it's 20 20. so at the
end of the day if obviously this
probably will never happen again in this
certain circumstance but you just have
to go with your gut instincts that's the
only thing you can do um my G's go with
your gut instinct and if you fail you
fell but that's the thing man great wish
comes great reward like these guys
didn't know what was going to happen
when they moved in for the lips grab the
lips yeah and luckily for them it passes
but I'm sure if you go around trying to
lips other girls they probably got
smacked a couple times oh yeah so yeah
before I wouldn't go advising just lips
because yeah that's assault but
um yeah bro like if a girl's giving you
Vibes you're just gonna have to move
about it just fight back yeah you gotta
have to fight back she was staring you
were staring and you just your legs
weren't working I've been there oh yeah
yeah you're thinking she caught me
looking at me and the tune isn't banging
enough for me to you know come forward
and you know give her a long two step in
front of it it's just it's just not the
right song so yeah you gotta
I know you could have what you should
have done grab a drink and do a lap grab
a drink do a lap if she's still trying
to find you yeah that's something
otherwise she's just staring at the wall
she's just staring as a crazy person
yeah yeah she likes what she sees in
this direction and you just happen to be
standing there so don't take it to heart
grab a drink do it do a lap bring your
drink over to her grab her by the hand
and just like do you want to drink I've
got one you want to come get a drink get
a lollipop the lollipop days yeah man
yeah man get a lollipop
yeah I don't think that happens anymore
post covered I don't think they do that
anymore
the pram that was a gateway drug those
Chopper chops that was a gateway drug
yeah that man patted us she would lips
are right your mouth it's getting over
here I go you didn't even have to look
at it you could be walking past if she's
really about it sure drapes out your
mouth like give me that I want a sweet
give me that I sure suck it she'll stir
you suck it give it back to you
and now we're lips in and that's the end
of that story facts [ __ ] the lollipop
never fails stop bringing your own
lollipops if anything
sweets
[Music]
how long you been in this industry you
know exactly why I got lollies bro
what's your mouth yeah reduce your
volume yeah let me bring these in my
shop
um but hopefully yeah bro yeah it's just
gonna it's just a matter of chest yeah
that's literally it that's the same with
anything like that you don't get a job
if you don't apply bro like you you have
to actually do something you have those
action stuff you're just waiting for the
girl to walk up and lips you and it's
never gonna happen I meant nothing it
will happen sometimes but yeah it's not
the girl you want to literally trust you
yeah like yeah no the most bang girl you
you've seen that you'll make an eye
contact isn't just gonna come up and
lift your face off it's always the the
it's always the thing that's going to
make a fool of herself tonight sure lips
you and you better hope she lives with
you first
cracks because yeah there's some dark
times that come out but anyway hope that
helps bro
um if not sorry but anyway guys that's
it for today as always thank you for
wasting your time with us we'll see you
next week if you want to see us sooner
head on over to patreon.com shits and
gigs and as always guys love love
[Music]